Westworld Season 3 explores a new world.
The robot Dolores has escaped the Westworld
park, and enters the real human world, in
the year 2058 . This season’s almost like
a reboot, with a new setting, new characters,
and new style, but with the same themes of
technology, freedom and control.
It’s also got Death Grips now.
The premiere begins with a beach – just
like Season 2 begins on a beach, and Season
1 ends on a beach.
Teddy once said that “Where the mountains
meet the sea”, the water will “wash the
past” off you, so “you can start again”
. Westworld is washing away the chaos of Season
2, and starting a new story in a new world.
Or maybe it’s just a fckin beach [let’s
not overthink it].
Jerry is a rich asshole in a Chinese mansion.
He’s angry cause he’s an investor in the
Westworld parks, and news just broke that
a hundred people died in the parks, when Dolores
and the hosts went on a rampage last season.
Jerry is rude and controlling to his wife
Eunice, so Jerry is instantly dislikeable.
We see futuristic technology – like there
are holograms you can see with special glasses.
And there are high-tech drugs called limbic
tabs.
People have implants on the roof of their
mouth, and when you put in a tab, it sends
a digital code to your brain to change your
mood.
The Westworld website says available flavours
include “Zen Garden”, “Agenda Achiever”,
and “Impulse”.
Jerry’s mansion has smart-home technology,
like an Alexa robot voice that controls the
place.
This whole human world is run by machines,
which makes it vulnerable to machines like
Dolores . Dolores comes in the night, and
hacks the smart-home system, turning off the
oxygen to knock everyone out.
Jerry tries to get help and the system says
“I'm afraid I can't do that” , which is
what HAL 9000 says in 2001: A Space Odyssey
. Dolores confronts Jerry, and says she met
Jerry before – he once came to the Westworld
park and Dolores.
“Don't you remember?”
Dolores says – “After everything we've
shared” . That’s just like what William
says to Dolores in Season 1 . But this time
Dolores is the powerful one, and the human
is the helpless.
Dolores knows all about Jerry.
Because last season, she went to the Forge
, which records data on all the memories and
DNA and minds of everyone who visits Westworld
. So Dolores knows that Jerry murdered his
last wife . She straps the hologram glasses
onto Jerry, to project images of his crime
– haunting him like the ghost of Christmas
past.
Dolores steals money from Jerry, and takes
data about a company called Incite , which
runs all the data tech in the world.
Dolores says her goal is “The origin of
a new species” – she wants the robot hosts
of Westworld to become their own free people
– which means she’ll have to deal with
humanity.
But Dolores says she doesn’t want to hurt
anyone, unless they try to hurt her.
Because Dolores has “hurt so many people”
already . Last season, Dolores killed lots
of humans and hosts who may have been innocent.
Her brutality drove her lover Teddy to suicide,
which seems to have changed Dolores’ mind.
She doesn’t wanna kill unless she has to.
So when Jerry tries to kill her, she uses
a hologram in the glasses to trick Jerry into
dying in his pool.
She tells Jerry’s wife Eunice that she’s
set her free from her murderous husband.
So Dolores is no longer an evil murderbot
taking revenge on the entire human species.
Now she fights for justice and liberation,
freeing not only hosts, but oppressed humans
like Eunice.
Dolores takes a swim in Jerry’s pool, which
could symbolise washing away her past sins,
and starting anew, just like Teddy said . The
title of this episode is Parce Domine, a Catholic
thing meaning “Spare, Lord, spare your people:
Be not angry with us forever” . Dolores
is less angry now – she’s more merciful
and just, like a benevolent god.
This could make Dolores a much more sympathetic
character than she was last season.
In Los Angeles, we meet Caleb.
He’s the first average person we’ve met
in this series – all the park guests in
past seasons were rich tourists, corporate
types, technologists and sadists.
Caleb’s just an ordinary guy, getting by
in LA in 2058.
He works in construction – this shot refers
to a famous photo from 1930s New York . But
Caleb works with a robot, and there’s driverless
cars, and all the city looks modern clean
and green.
Caleb says technology has made some things
better – but Caleb feels trapped . His mother
is sick, apparently with dementia or something,
because she no longer recognises him.
And he can barely afford her medical bills.
So Caleb turns to crime – and there’s
an app for that.
It’s called Rico, and it’s like Uber or
Taskrabbit for crime.
Its algorithm offers jobs based on your location
and profile – burglary, delivery, grand
theft auto, murder.
Everything’s anonymous, automatic, efficient,
and apparently untraceable – showrunner
Jonathan Nolan says it works on the blockchain,
like a Deep Web thing.
And it’s gamified – you get points and
badges and “crime coins”, and rate people
on their performance, which affects which
jobs you can get, like star ratings in Uber.
So Rico is a “parody” of our real-world
algorithmic “gig economy” . Caleb does
robberies and transport and stuff, but he
chooses not to do “personals” , meaning
he won’t do murder and kidnap and stuff.
So Caleb’s a very sympathetic character
– he only does crime to pay his mum’s
medical bills.
But Caleb feels trapped in a loop – these
shots of Caleb waking up each morning are
just like Dolores waking up in Season 1.
Caleb takes a job robbing an ATM, just like
the host Hector robs the saloon in Season
1.
Hector does the same robbery over and over
because his programming tells him to, just
like Caleb does these Rico jobs, over and
over, cause its algorithm tells him to.
Season 1 was about robots stuck in loops,
this season is about humans stuck in loops,
controlled by code.
Caleb meets with some criminal buddies – Ash
and Giggles.
Giggles is played by NFL player Marshawn Lynch,
and he’s got a sick mood shirt that changes
depending on how he feels.
Ash has a device that blocks surveillance
and blasts Death Grips at max volume.
So this is a stylish, cyberpunk dystopia – these
guys barely scrape by, but they look fine
while they do it.
The Westworld parks are run by the Delos corporation.
They have a meeting, in the aftermath of the
massacre last season.
And it’s run by Charlotte Hale, except we
know that’s not really Charlotte – last
season, Dolores killed Charlotte, and impersonated
her with Dolores’ brain in a Charlotte body.
When Dolores left the park, she created a
new Charlotte – so whose brain is in there?
Maybe it’s one of these five host brains
she took from the park.
It can’t be just Dolores, cause we’ve
seen Dolores with this Charlotte last season
[and in trailers].
It’s not Teddy, cause Dolores left him behind
in the Sublime [Windows XP heaven].
It’s not Angela, cause she blew up in the
Cradle.
It’s not Maeve, or Bernard.
Maybe it could be Hector or Armistice?
Or there could be a twist, like maybe it’s
not a host at all, but a copy of a human,
like the James Delos clone.
Or it could be a totally new person, like
a host child.
Whoever this Charlotte is, she’s working
with Dolores to influence Delos – she takes
the company private , and says to “resume
host production” – maybe Dolores wants
to keep making hosts, so that her “new species”
can grow . Maybe she wants the parks to keep
running because she agrees with Ford, that
hosts need to suffer in the park before they
can become conscious , like Dolores did.
To control the board, Charlotte needs approval
from another board member, who isn’t at
the meeting – this must be William.
William owns Westworld, he’s the majority
shareholder . But for years, he’s not come
to meetings, preferring to spend his time
in the park . He must leave this “machine
shareholder” to vote on stuff for him, and
it agrees with Charlotte.
Last time we saw [human] William, he was alive
in the park.
But where is he now, and does he still control
this machine?
Maybe Charlotte is hacking this machine – like
Dolores hacks Jerry’s home.
Either way, Charlotte takes control, and she
blames the whole Westworld massacre on Bernard
.
So Bernard is on the run.
He’s left his old life behind for a simpler
one, like The Hound in Game of Thrones, with
a very similar outfit.
Bernard works on a farm, and he finds an injured
cow with flies buzzing round it.
In Season 2, Dolores tells the story of some
cows getting an infection, spread by flies.
Teddy says he’d protect and help the infected
cows.
But Dolores said she’d kill the weak cows,
so the strong cows can live . So this continues
the theme of mercy versus survival – Parce
Dominem.
Should the weak die so that the strong can
survive?
Should the weak humans die, so that the hosts
can grow and thrive?
Bernard tries to help the hurt cow, but his
human boss sends it for slaughter – just
like humanity may be slaughtered, unless Dolores
is merciful.
Inside the slaughterhouse, humans butcher
animals – just like hosts were butchered
in the Westworld park, in the “livestock”
section.
Then Bernard talks to himself, in diagnostic
mode – he seems to have two distinct personalities.
There’s the more human conscious side, and
the more robotic unconscious side – they
talk to each other, like Gollum and Smeagol
in Lord of the Rings.
Bernard doesn’t trust his robo side – he
questions whether he’s been influenced by
Dolores . Cause this Bernard was created by
Dolores last season – maybe Dolores left
some backdoor to hack or control Bernard’s
subconscious mind.
Bernard’s identity and mental state have
always been complicated.
Bernard is a host based on a human called
Arnold – Arnold Weber is an anagram of Bernard
Lowe.
Now, Bernard uses a fake identity, Armand
Delgado – which is an anagram for Damaged
Arnold.
So Armand is an alias of a copy of a copy
of a dead man – and each time he’s remade,
he’s changed, rearranged like the letters
of his name.
So Bernard is all scrambled, and he’s struggling
to figure out who he is.
Bernard is attacked by some workers who recognise
him as a fugitive – so Bernard lets out
his robo side, which is a powerful fighter
– it’s like Eddie Brock unleashing Venom.
Bernard says that he’s trying to save the
human race from Dolores , but they don’t
listen.
So he’s forced to hurt the people he’s
trying to save, like that cow.
So like in previous seasons, Bernard’s story
is confusing, but at least everything seems
to be happening within one timeline again.
Dolores goes to a fancy corporate event for
Incite, the tech company that runs the world’s
data.
Dolores has seduced the face of Incite, Liam
Dempsey, and is using him to get information
on the company.
The party is full of wealth and luxury and
douchebags – Liam’s friend brags that
his drink is worth more than people earn in
a year . Meanwhile, Caleb can’t afford his
mum’s medical bills – so this is a deeply
unequal society, which is not so different
to reality.
Showrunner Jonathan Nolan says this is what
the world might be like if we continue the
way we’re going – with a small number
of people holding even more of the wealth
and power, controlling everyone else through
technology . Liam’s friend gets high and
says nothing is real, we’re all “living
in a simulation” man . It is a common theory
that the so-called real world in this show
is just another fake reality, or another park,
like Futureworld.
But the showrunners are clearly interested
in exploring our reality, so having this guy
rant about simulations might be their way
of dismissing the theory and saying that this
is the real real world.
Dolores says that a part of the brain called
the Nucleus accumbens evolved to make humans
believe in God, which is a loose interpretation
of the neuroscience, but there is evidence
linking the nucleus accumbens to religious
experiences . So Dolores’ point is that
believing that we’re inside someone’s
simulation is basically the same as believing
we’re in a world created by a God.
Either way, you’re just believing in a higher
power because that’s what our brains have
evolved to believe – humans, like robots,
can only follow their code.
Dolores sees Rehoboam, a computer that processes
all the data for the Incite corporation.
Its algorithm gives strategies that tell people
how to live – what you should buy, what
job you should work, who you should date – Incite
offers “A path for everyone” . In Season
1, Dolores believed in “a path for everyone”
– but then she realised that was her programming,
trapping her in a loop of suffering . Humans
had been free, but now they’ve built technology
that traps them in loops as well.
Dolores uses a sick cyberbike and spy-glasses
to listen in to a meeting between Liam and
an Incite person called Martel.
She says someone has been accessing Rehoboam
, through Liam – so this probably means
Dolores got in by exploiting Liam’s access.
Martel threatens to use Rehoboam’s data
to assassinate Liam . Liam admits to Dolores
that he has no real power at Incite.
The only person who controls Rehoboam is its
original architect – a mysterious guy called
Serac . Liam implies that Serac may have murdered
Liam’s father, who was Serac’s business
partner . Dolores gets captured by Martin,
a hardarse fixer for Liam – Martin figured
out that Dolores was using a fake identity.
So Martin uses Rico to hire someone to brings
some drugs to kill Dolores – and Caleb gets
the delivery job . Martin injects Dolores
with the lethal drugs, but they do nothing,
cause she’s a robot.
Dolores summons a driverless car, and inside
is a host copy of Martin.
This whole thing is Dolores’ trap – like
with Jerry, she must have used data from the
Forge to predict and manipulate Martin.
She kills Martin and replaces him with the
host Martin loyal to her.
So with this Martin and the Charlotte, Delores
is using hosts to infiltrate powerful tech
companies, to take over the human world and
help the birth of the new host species.
Martin’s men attack, and they have a shoot-out
in MacArthur Park – Dolores goes all Terminator
on their asses.
As a robot, she’s fast, and tough.
But she’s not invulnerable.
She walks wounded into a tunnel, where Caleb
finds her.
Caleb was once in the army with his mate Francis
– played by Kid Cudi.
But something went wrong, Francis got killed,
and Caleb is traumatised.
The army put him in a psych program, but instead
of a human therapist, he has to talk to a
chatbot with the voice and personality of
his dead friend like some Black Mirror shit.
And this Francis-bot isn’t like the real
Francis – the bot encourages compliance
with the system and ‘playing the game’,
when the real Francis was rebellious . So
Caleb rejects the bot and says he needs “someone
… real” – and that’s when he meets
Dolores.
So the irony will be that the robot Dolores
is the realest person in Caleb’s life – cause
unlike everyone else trapped in a loop, Dolores
follows her own plan.
In Season 1, Dolores fell into the arms of
William, who became the Man in Black – William
taught her that humans are selfish and cruel.
Maybe Caleb will show Dolores that humans
can be good and selfless.
Showrunner Jonathan Nolan says Caleb represents
“humanness and humility and kindness”
. But Caleb is still mysterious.
He casually mentions that he’s been shot
in the head before , and his mother did say
he’s not her son . So there are theories
that Caleb is actually some robot replacement.
Though that could undermine the whole human
good idea . But we’ve gotta question whether
this meeting of Dolores and Caleb really is
random chance.
Caleb was brought to Dolores by a job on the
Rico app.
Rico is meant to be untrackable, but it’d
be a cool twist if the crime app was actually
controlled by Incite.
The easiest way to prevent rebellion is to
make rebellion part of the system, right – like
in the Matrix, when the One and Zion are actually
programmed by the machines, or like the prison
industry in the real world.
Throughout the episode, we get these shots
where some system sees “divergence” and
anomalies in the places where Dolores and
Caleb go.
Maybe this is Rehoboam, seeing Dolores and
Caleb as flickers in the world’s data.
Maybe Serac, who controls Rehoboam, deliberately
brings Caleb and Dolore together for some
higher plan.
At the very least, Incite is fcking with Caleb.
He interviews to get a better job , but gets
rejected by a company’s “strategy group”
. Rehoboam’s thoughts are called “Strategies”
– so it seems like Incite’s data is preventing
him from getting hired.
Maybe cause Rehoboam is aware of his criminal
activity on Rico, or is listening to his anti-authority
[rebellious] attitudes in his calls with the
Francis-bot.
Or maybe it’s some arbitrary reason – the
point is that through data technology, humanity
has handed its freedom away to machines.
So even outside the Westworld park, we can’t
be sure who’s in control and what’s real.
Bernard takes a boat to the Westworld parks
– his map seems to confirm that the Westworld
is on an island in the South China Sea.
Bernard says he’s “looking for a friend”,
and after the credits, we see the friend he’s
looking for.
Maeve wakes up in an unfamiliar place.
Last season, sacrificed herself to save her
daughter.
The techs Felix and Sylvester were told to
salvage her . And it looks like they’ve
put her in a new park – Warworld, a simulation
of Italy in the second world war . Bernard’s
goal is apparently to get Maeve’s help to
stop Dolores from destroying humanity . So
Maeve might finally leave Westworld and see
the real world for the first time.
In Season 1, Maeve’s programmed narrative
said that she “Crossed the shining sea”
, to a “new world” – where she “can
be whoever the fuck” she wants . Now she’ll
get to do that for real.
But first, she’ll kill some Ns.
Westworld has a new intro sequence, that highlights
some of themes of the season.
There’s a dandelion, with its florets traced
by geometric lines – like how the natural
world follows mathematical laws, and the human
mind can be described with lines of code.
There’s an eagle flying into a jet engine,
like Icarus at the sun – like how humanity
is destroying itself in the pursuit of technology.
But the main imagery is of reflection – repetitions,
and symmetry.
Season One was about hosts controlled by code.
Season Three is about humans controlled by
code.
Delores was powerless against humans, now
she's the powerful one.
She meets Caleb, as she met William.
Bernard worked on host livestock, now he works
on animal livestock.
Images lines and phrases are repeated and
refracted in different situations.
This is even reflected in the architecture
– all this glass, mirrors, water.
This shot also resembles the famous painting
The Creation of Adam, which appeared in Season
1.
We see dividing cells, cause Dolores wants
the birth of a new host species . So there
is some optimism in this new intro.
But the intro ends with the logo in bright
red – hinting that despite all the changes,
Westworld remains a bloody affair – violent
delights, violent ends.
The intro also shows Rehoboam, cause this
season is all about data and algorithms controlling
humanity.
This might sound like a sci-fi idea, but big
tech has been using data to predict and control
us for years – and you can read all about
this in The Age of Surveillance Capitalism
by Shoshana Zuboff . It’s a deep exploration
of the systems that increasingly control our
lives, it’s at least as scary as anything
in Westworld, and it’s real.
You can get it on audiobook for free right
now by signing up for a trial with Audible.
Members get an audiobook each month, and if
you cancel, you keep the audiobooks.
You can listen in your driverless car, or
on your cyber-bike.
Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Remember to like and subscribe and press the
bell – otherwise the algorithm might not
show you our videos.
We’re holding livestreams right after each
episode of Westworld Season 3, at about 10:30pm
Eastern Time Sundays.
Patreon supporters can watch livestreams after
broadcast.
Thanks to Patrons Nolan Strout, the bando
gora, Hazard Alhosni, Ben Katz, Tanya, Travlis
Hallingquest, and drug dog.
Cheers.